this is just strategic stupidity on the  part of local commanders who see the  power station supplies 20 of electricity  to ukraine that's a big facility let's  bomb it um without thinking about the  wider implications  [Music]  of  [Music]  are likely to be worse  with more death  more suffering  and more destruction  as the russian armed forces  bring in heavier  weaponry  and continue their attacks  across the country  and of course the only way to  implement a no-fly zone is to send nato  planes fighter planes into ukrainian  airspace  and then impose that no-fly zone by  shooting down russian planes  we did that  we end up with something that could end  in a full-fledged war in europe  involving many more countries  [Music]  and  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  is  [Music]